der krieg im jemen gilt als die
schlimmste humanitäre katastrophe der
welt es droht eine schlachtung die
hafenstadt hudaida die 70 prozent der
versorgung des landes sicherstellt das
könnte eine unvorstellbare hungersnot
auslösen
doch ende 2018 kam es in stocken zu
friedensgesprächen heute in vechta
kompakt friedens hoffnung im jemen
[Musik]
zum hintergrund die reval dem arabischen
raum 2011 erfassten auch den jemen und
langzeitpräsident saale trat zurück
eine neue verfassung sollte das land in
einen demokratischen und föderalen staat
transformieren
aber die schiitischen hut ist aus der
ärmsten region fühlten sich aufgrund der
geplanten dezentralisierung
benachteiligt der vormalige präsident
saale schlug sich auf ihre seite
gemeinsam nahmen sie bei einem
staatsstreich 2014 die hauptstadt sanaa
ein und der jemen schlitterte in einen
bürgerkrieg den vierten seit 1962 die
ludwigs besetzten im märz 2015 die
hafenstadt aden und der
übergangspräsident harvey floh nach
saudi arabien
daraufhin startete riad gemeinsam mit 15
staaten eine militär operation
legitimiert durch eine resolution des
sicherheitsrats der vereinten nationen
luftangriffe sollten die wut ist
zurückdrängen und die herrschaft des
präsidenten hardy wiederherstellen zu
militärinterventionen gehört auch die
blockade von wirtschaftsgütern und
hilfslieferungen das vorgehen ernte
zusätzlich kritik weil der großteil der
getöteten und verwundeten zivilisten
opfer der luftschläge ist nach dem
saudischen eingreifen kamen auch die
iran und die hisbollah einspielen
sie unterstützen die hooters durch
ausbildung militärberater und
waffenlieferungen dschihadisten aus
saudi arabien hatten sich bereits 2009
zur al kaida auf der arabischen
halbinsel mit sitz im jemen zusammen
geschlossen
auch anhänger der terror miliz nutzten
das chaos und konnten fuß fassen
wer ist nun im jemen aktiv die
wesentlichen akteure sind die regierung
und der presse
den hd sie wird von saudi arabien und
der militärallianz unterstützt die usa
leisteten bis november 2018 logistische
hilfe die südliche widerstandsfront sie
wird vom boden drucken der vereinigten
arabischen emirate unterstützt diese
sorgen für sicherheit in der temporären
hauptstadt aden und helfen den
wiederaufbau staatlicher strukturen sich
aber nach gebiete zurück die unter
kontrolle der hub ist oder dschihadisten
stehen die hutu-rebellen diese haben
ende 2017 die allianz mit ex-präsident
saale aufgekündigt wenig später wurde er
von ihnen ermordet
sie kontrollieren weiterhin den norden
des landes und die hauptstadt sana
nicht zu vergessen die dschihadisten
gruppe al-kaida werden die es anhänger
trainingslager betreiben und
terroranschläge verüben kontrollieren al
qaida kräfte seit jahren teile des
südens zu aktuellen lage im juni 2018
hat die von saudi arabien und den
emiraten geführte koalition die
operation golden victory gestattet damit
soll die von putins besetzt die
hafenstadt hudaida am roten meer erobert
werden
über diesen zweitgrößten hafen des jemen
kommen die meisten hilfslieferungen
da ist aber auch für die versorgung von
sana und des mute gebietes im norden
unverzichtbar die koalition und die
jemenitischen streitkräfte haben bis
november den östlichen stadtrand
eingenommen
eine blockade des hafens und ein
weiterer angriff auf das zentrum würden
auf heftigen widerstand stoßen und eine
unvorstellbare hungerkatastrophe
bewirken
die zunehmende kritik am vorgehen sowie
der große internationale druck infolge
der ermordung des saudischen
journalisten katar drängten riad eine
verhandlungslösung für den jemen zu
suchen
mit dem november 2008 10 kam es daher zu
einer feuerpause die friedensgespräche
ermöglicht unter vermittlung des us
sondergesandten für den jemen
verhandelten regierungsvertreter und hut
wie rebellen im dezember in stockholm
erstmals nach zwei jahren im
wesentlichen einigte man sich auf einen
waffenstillstand in weida und auf einen
gefangenen
die übergabe der hafen kontrolle an eine
dritte partei würde vor allem
hilfslieferungen wieder möglich machen
ein uno team soll den abzug der hut ließ
koordinieren
die umsetzung erfolgt gab es ja schlecht
wenn viele fragen sind offen und es
kommt immer wieder zu verstößen gegen
die vereinbarungen sogar das ohne
überwachung steam wurde bereits
beschlossen
ein ausblick es ist sehr schwierig die
frieden chancen einzuschätzen
so ist eine fortsetzung des krieges
genauso möglich wie ein schleppender
friedensprozess der irgendwann zu
einigermaßen stabilen verhältnissen
führt die dritte möglichkeit besteht in
einem festwagen des krieges und der de
facto zweiteilung des landes sind in den
nord süd haider kann entscheidend sein
von internationaler seite kommt es nun
darauf an friedensgespräche zu forcieren
eine großoffensive zu unterbinden und
damit auch umfangreiche hilfslieferungen
zu ermöglichen